- simile say his majority Islamic
country which means there are people of
other faiths in the country we get along
fine with each other we have never had
any major problem with them we practice
the teachings of the legion which tells
us that we should be tolerant of other
people's faith so there have been
attempts though to proselytize for
particular versions of Islam we see
what's happening Brunei for example and
indeed in the Borneo portion of Malaysia
there have been a number of quite
serious terrorist incidents against
security forces yes there was before but
now we have a very little problem there
either so how do you think the problem
should be addressed I think we should go
to the root of this matter people don't
just get angry and do horrible things
unless there is some reason they have
what they see is that the governments of
Muslim countries have not been able to
do anything about their their problem
particularly with their problem over
Israel for example so people tend to
take the law into their own hands as in
modern society we know about NGOs
non-government organizations
non-government organizations formed
simply because they feel government was
not doing the things that they should be
done and I think there is a lot of
frustration in the Muslim world are very
extreme some are moderate but there is
still a sense of frustration over their
inability to resolve their problem what
you mean by the problem with Israel well
this was Palestine before it was amended
so
it's justifiable for is to do what it
wants because Israel exists no it's not
justified by at all this is pent-up
frustration that is resulting in all
these violence not illiquid what could
be done you can't abolish the State of
Israel or wipe it out can you
well he's Rael is no longer his Raley's
occupied the whole of Palestine you
should at least move out all those
settlements there I went to I went to
Palestine I found that I was being
checked not by Palestinians but by the
Israel so you you feel that if Israel
returned to the 1967 borders for example
that that would put an end to is
terrorism
I think the Arabs generally agreed to a
two-state solution I think that should
be the way and if that happened you
believe that that would stop the Islamic
state which after all is at the moment
attacking on Muslim lands I know it is
very unfortunate is not part of the
teachings of Islam but it is an
expression of their frustration over
something that they find themselves
unable to resolve because they are up
against very powerful nations I mean
there are those who would say that the
root of is certainly is the failure of
the Arab Spring to establish proper
democracy they contribute yes but the
main thing is because there is a feeling
that Muslims generally are being
oppressed their countries have been
invaded hundreds of thousands of their
people have been bombed and killed so
how do they react to this what about the
implementation of attitudes towards
women or towards homosexuals or towards
minorities which frankly according to
the tenets of the United Nations for
example are unacceptable
there are some which are
unacceptable in their practices but you
must remember that other people have
other values other cultures we have to
learn how to tolerate at one time all
the English women will cover it up right
to the tool when if it came comes to a
choice where do you want your country
Malaysia to be we are on the side of
Western values are on the side of no we
are not making any choices but Western
or Eastern we have our own set of values
some of them I dread perhaps from
Western sources some are from our own
original beliefs and understandings
dr. Maha thank you very much today for
joining me are young welcome